how's it going guys welcome back design
patterns episode four today we're going
to be talking about the object pool
and this is a pattern that basically uh
helps you a little bit with caching and
just keeping your memory aligned but and
not having to recreate variables that
you've already used so something gets
reused constantly and uh maybe
normally you would allocate de-allocate
a bunch of times if you want to avoid
all those
reallocations deallocations use this
object pool and with this object pool
basically you're going to create it once
and then whenever you use it you pull it
from the pool and then whenever you put
it back you just put it back in the pool
and you might reset the memory every
time like you know just set it to zeros
or to its default value but before i
hold up a quick example i'm going to
show you a web page that basically has a
great example and i'll leave a link to
this
of course with all these patterns
there are tons of of links and examples
online and you can find them usually you
have to search for c plus versions if
you want to stick with that because
they're often in java or python or
something but uh yeah let's take a look
at the object pool get a sense of so
here on this uh source making they have
this design patterns book i don't know
how good it is i haven't read it myself
or anything here's the web page i'll
leave a link down below
and here's uh the basic gist of it if
you want to read it but it's basically
as i explained it's pretty pretty
straightforward so yeah think of it as
like a warehouse of stuff if you don't
have the stuff you need to order it or
create it and once you have it it's in
your warehouse right so it just exists
there and you can go grab it whenever
you want but once someone is using it no
one else can get it either so if you
need multiple you got to create more and
when you're done with it you put it back
in the warehouse so that's essentially
it it's kind of like borrowing from a
pool in general so let's check out
object pool and c plus plus see what
they got going on here they're using
list io and string so their resource is
essentially just an integer here it is
there's the value they have just a
constructor to set it to zero reset to
zero but it's essentially the resource
is just an integer and they've wrapped
their integer in a class there's
probably going to be something else
because an integer is obviously
very very simple and here's the object
pool note that this is a singleton
that's fine you can see they got a
static instance here privately and uh as
we talked about a little bit in the
singleton instance i noted that this
didn't work but this does work if at the
end somewhere outside your class you do
this sort of thing
so
you basically have to declare it outside
the class and initialize it but you can
see they have a private list of
resources and this this is resources
pointers now uh you don't want to use
list
list is going to scatter your memory but
they're only using pointers so these
little pointers are going to be all over
the place in general you probably want
to avoid using lists it doesn't put
things in uh contiguous order they're
just scatter all of your memory so
usually you want to use an array or a
vector but the this is this is a small
enough example it doesn't matter
you do want to use a list sometimes when
your object here is huge but in this
case their object is a pointer so it's
tiny so you definitely don't want it to
be a list so
that's something they this whoever wrote
this probably didn't know or realized
but that's the thing so you don't want
to copy examples exactly sometimes i
mean you can it would work but it's just
going to be something that's going to be
like oh why would you do this it's bad
for your cpu
all right so here we go they have the
old git instance uh we saw this in the
singleton uh so that's pretty standard
and of course you want this as a single
10 otherwise you'll be generating a
bunch of different object pools you want
one it's essentially a manager of this
stuff all right and then you have get
resources so whenever you need a
resource it's going to get a pointer to
it which means uh you know it's just
access to the memory that it created so
if your resources list is empty it
creates a new one with a new resource if
this obviously wouldn't compile uh
because they're not creating the
resource correctly but you know i don't
think they compiled this code or test it
thoroughly but yeah so it goes else if
they if you already have one if you
already have resources available then
they're just getting a pointer to the
front resource
which is the very first thing on the
list and then they're popping that
pointer off the list and returning the
resource so essentially you now have the
pointer reduces the size of the list so
maybe this is why they're using lists is
because they're using this pop front in
front this is kind of slow in an array
or a vector because it has to rearrange
everything i believe
but in a list it doesn't have to
rearrange the whole array so maybe this
is why they decided to use a list
because they're using this method here
all right and then when you're done with
the resource you call return resource
and it's just a pointer to the object
once again and
we call object.reset which we saw
earlier just sets it to zero and then we
add it back to our list
now uh what's important about this
is uh we're only passing around pointers
so some pointers might be created and
deleted created
and yeah
and de-allocated a little bit but uh the
actual object itself never
nothing here calls delete on it it never
gets deleted once it's created so
that's the thing you don't see anywhere
here delete resource
and uh since this is a static singleton
it's actually okay because statics
exists through the lifetime of your
program whenever your program exits it's
going to clean up all those
however if this was not a single 10
you'd be have to be a lot more careful
about memory leaks
but there is another kind of bug here
and that's that this grows it could grow
infinitely large if you just keep
grabbing objects it's going to endlessly
grow so you probably want to have some
kind of cap on it like hey i can maximum
manage 100 objects or whatever
because uh
some clever person could be like well
just endlessly grab resources and then
you run out of memory and you crash
so that can happen uh in this particular
instance a bit of a naive instance but
still makes the point and here we go
just as you expect a tester for it they
create a couple instances
uh they use this pool to get an instance
i create one two
these are
nothing's there they want to turn them
into something so they call get resource
you can call set value on the resource
etc etc okay so back
into our code now i've already made a
new folder for object pool over here
i've made a cmake that's ready to go
uh and i've made it main that's blank
and ready to go and of course in our
mid-level cmake i've added subdirectory
object pool so that it uh makes that so
let's go ahead and do this uh we'll
follow a pretty similar pattern uh we're
gonna have a resource dot h to handle
that and yeah we can do the same thing
in fact uh let's save some time i know
we've made these kind of long so i'm
gonna try to wrap them up a little
quicker here sometimes
i think it just
distracts a little bit once it gets too
long so i'm going to grab this and we'll
just clean up things as we go
what do we need here
i don't think we need anything maybe c
standard live
yeah probably that's probably it
all right so we got a resource class
it's private privately got this value we
got a we got a set and reset now of
course these could be anything you're
supposed to use this with large objects
in general this is a tiny object so it's
kind of a bad example but it still gets
the point across so just keep that in
mind so there we have a resource okay
let's go ahead and make our
manager
um
i'm going to call this warehouse
all right that's i just like that
because i like that example so i'm going
to once again copy everything from that
and we'll clean up as we go
so we got our object pool we're gonna
have to include a few things
i'm gonna leave this list i think maybe
they also made it list because this is
supposed to be used for large objects
and list is good with large objects it's
just that in this example it just
happens to not be a large object so keep
that in mind with the whole list in
object pool large objects it's for large
objects you're using tiny objects
probably doesn't matter if you allocate
and de-allocate them so much
so yeah i think that uh that covers most
of it there
all right this looks pretty good for the
most point most part let's go ahead and
just name this object pool to warehouse
all right rename all there we go
there we go we got uh privately there's
our there's our resources
we got our instance so i'm going to move
up a little bit we got a private
constructor
and uh we'll leave this here publicly we
got the get instance so you can get
access to the warehouse
a little uh singleton method there and
uh here's a get resource uh yeah we'll
leave this uh creating new return
existing i'm also
going to leave
this at the top of these just so uh
there's no confusion and hey we're
putting our sources up there source is
always good example
sample derived from there we go boom
boom
all right good enough looks good yeah
we'll use this front this is fine they
yeah there's an error here though they
do need to put
oops select all okay yeah when you
create your new resource you need to
make sure you have these for your
constructor and you could even do some
you know this could be a factory you get
resource call factory you know there's a
lot of things you could do you could
essentially turn this into like a
warehouse that is also kind of a factory
if you want you know there's uh
you can be creative with these for what
you're and go with what your program
needs
all right and then we got return
resource here at the end so basically
instead of calling
create or new and delete in general
you're going to call get resource and
return resource
and uh yeah i guess that's that's about
it for this little warehouse so let's go
into our main here and let's go over
their example i'm just going to copy and
paste the example in here let me check
one more thing on this warehouse okay
yeah we got the static instance at the
bottom so that should be
should be good initializing to zero is
the same as no pointer i generally like
doing null pointer because i think it's
a little more clear but they're the same
thing some compilers will complain if
you don't put in the right one
all right back to our main let's have a
look here
and obviously object pool we renamed to
warehouse so let's go ahead and do that
here too
i'm gonna hit uh oh yeah we gotta
get rid of the main here
let's clean this up real quick
there we go there we go
there we go well we need to include
our warehouse
and warehouse needs to include
a resource yeah i think we're good i
think we've explained most of it let's
go ahead and give this a run oh uh give
this a run by changing this to object
pool
hit play let's see if we get any errors
we need to fix nope looks like we're
good to go and uh yeah there we go
seems to do what it's supposed to do and
you can see they put the memory
addresses in here which is great uh you
can see the first one has this memory
address let's look at the last few
digits 6e0 and when it returns it stays
the same memory address so that's
important the object
the object is staying the same we're
just essentially passing around pointers
to it
so we can walk through this
yeah here we create a new or we get the
instance of the warehouse we're going to
need that to work with uh we created a
couple
local temporary resources and we gather
and we have our pool create those and we
can call the set value method and let's
see out is just the demo
we got the value it should be 10 and
this here is the address
since this is a pointer it's going to be
the memory address and then we do the
same thing with the second one so to a
different value check its value check
its memory address and then we call
return resources and then we do the same
same thing once again and we basically
just check that they're reset but there
it's reusing the same space and memory
as you can see when you get them again
they're reset but they're the same
memory location
and that's basically it there's not a
whole lot else to it this example could
get very a lot more complicated a lot of
things are churning in my head about
things i want to over explain but i'll
probably just end up making it more
complicated if i do so i'm going to
leave it at this and let me know if you
have any questions about the object pool
i believe i've covered everything at
least in theory and talk
about what you need to do and know all
right thanks for watching see you guys
in the next one keep going peace out
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you